more nutrition truths that Wellness
influencers don't want you to know even
though the world is obsessed with the
risks of fatness you're actually twice
as likely to die from being underweight
than overweight a vegetable could fart
on your cracker or chips and it can be
labeled as made with real vegetables
a fat-free salad may actually be less
nutritious than one with a generous
amount of dressing we need some fat to
absorb the nutrients in those veg
the added fiber in Your Greens powders
or your keto candy is more likely to
make you feel bloated than it is to keep
you full or protect you from chronic
disease
canola oil actually has a uniquely
favorable omega-6 to Omega-3 ratio it's
only toxic to influencers because it's
an accessible and non-exclusionary buy
and full fat Dairy may actually be
healthier than skimmed
[Applause]
fruits are going to make the most
influencers mad